hello everyone and welcome to some human
on human action featuring Hikaru
Nakamura versus magnus carlsen it's
around 6 of the London chess classic and
it's a pretty big game for Hikaru
Nakamura so far in classical games and
Nakamura had a pretty terrible score
against Magnus Carlsen
of all the games they played a Nakamura
won only one game I think it was the one
in 2013 in Bilbao and lost 12 games to
Magnus Carlsen so the score is 12 to 1
with 23 draws that's a that's not a very
good result here Nakamura has the white
pieces and more importantly tomorrow is
hakanaku Morris 30th birthday so this
win this one would definitely mean a lot
to him you know yeah you know for when
he wakes up and he's a birthday that he
defeated the world champion and for the
standings in the tournament so let's see
this game Nakamura has the white pieces
and we have E 4 so already seems like
it's gonna be an exciting game he 592 f3
Knight to c6 and d4 Nakamura goes for
the scotch and probably probably
inspired by recent alpha0 games and his
his games against Garry Kasparov you
capture Sun d4 Knight captures on d4 and
Knight to f6 and Knight captures on c6 b
captures on c6 and now II five the
Schmidt nice variation we have Queen to
e7 Queen to e2 and Knight to d5 and here
I believe it was a Kasparov who played
this against Wesley so in the in the
ultimate blitz challenge c4 was played
and then there's Bishop to a6 but in
this game Nakamura goes for the early
age for preparing a very early rock lift
also probably inspired by games of
alphas alpha zero Bishop to b7 c for now
knife to b6 and rook to h3 Queen to e6
by Carson f4 we have castles and a for
now and I remember there was a game
between
in Gary Kasparov and Anatoly Karpov
Karpov I think our pool was playing I
don't know if carpet was white or black
but either Karpov played age 4 and a 4
or it was age 5 and a 5 and Kasparov
said this is this is no way to play
chess you can push age 5 and a 5 or a H
for an 8 a 4 doesn't matter I went into
a deep think and then crush him but
we'll see how Nakamura pulls it off
d5 by Carlsen now a 5 giving Carlsen two
options well three but I guess nice to
eight isn't something you want to play
since a six volt repair bishop but he
can go Knight to d7 or he can accept the
challenge by playing Knight captures on
c4 and Carson accepts it he plays nine
characters on c4 b3 now the Knight has
nowhere to go
B Bishop to b4 with check we have King
to f2 and now Knight captures on a fire
and there was a this I don't think this
was an easy decision for Carlsen if you
play something like Bishop it back to c5
then it really depends what nakamura
place if he plays the King do you want
you can always repeat moves but if he at
some points decides to play King to g3
then you have this maneuver Bishop to g1
now not allowing the King to escape
through F 2 or H 2 so probably rope to H
1 kicking the bishop back but now Bishop
to d4 would an attack on the rook and
after something like rook to a4 now
Queen to g6 check checking the King and
attacking now the night that is
undefended and b1 you have to react to
this and the only move is Queen to g4
blocking the check and also checking the
black King and after the exchange
happens now night to e3 check came to f2
if you captured an Bishop capture so
King to f3 Knight captures on f1 now a6
first kicking the bishop bishop to a8
and now rook captures on d4 but now it
seems like your knight is trapped but
actually
Qasim would have a way out
see five would an attack on the rook
rook to d1 and now II for creating a
discovered check from this Bishop on a8
and also creating an outpost on d3 for
the night so after King F 293 the knight
is able to save itself Bishop captures D
captures with checking King captures
it's a pretty it's a pretty equal
endgame Carson would have would have a
nice bishop against the night but still
both rooks are on the board both pairs
of rooks are on the board pretty equal
so after King to have to cross and
decided to go for the for the feisty
variation Knight captures on a5 we have
Bishop to d2 and this is the problem you
can capture the bishop to capture Knight
captures protecting the b3 pawn this
Knight has nowhere to go
so after Bishop d2 see if I was played
and now of course this was Nakamura's
idea all along rook captures a knight on
a5 Bishop captures and Bishop captures
so two pieces for a rook Queen to a5 by
Carson he has to control the c2 square
if you allow Queen to c2 then this c5
pawn is probably gonna fall and moves
like Knight to c3 to b5 are coming
attacking a7 and c7 the bishop is also
attacking c7 so Carson has to defend the
C 2 square
nice to see three now Queen captures on
f4 with check King to g1 nakamora
doesn't mind giving up another pawn we
have rook H to e8 and this was a this
was also probably not a very easy
decision as you could go for something
like d4 and after d4 Knight b5 attacking
c7 and after a six Knight captures and
our rook to d7 Queen to c4 rook captures
Bishop captures King captors and Queen
captures on c5 with check King b8 now p
d6 check King to a8 and Bishop captures
on a6
rocked the c8 now preparing ideas like
rook to c1 check the Queen is covering
h2 but then either Bishop captures and
this
force a draw Bishop to c4 it's a pretty
equal game the material the material is
equal so hard to say probably a draw so
after Kings to g1 cross and plays rook
HD EA instead of d4 knife to b5 now and
here we have a six rook to f3 first
kicking the Queen away Queen captures on
e5 Queen captures rook captures and now
Bishop captures on c7 attacking both of
Carson's rooks rook to e8 now Bishop
captures rook captures and Knight back
to a3 and at the end of this variation
cross and is down a piece but he does
have three points for the piece so can
he core do this a piece against three
pawns we saw that alpha zero can pull
off a piece against against four pawns
but that was a bishop pair so let's see
how he card does this against the world
champion rook to d7 Carson defends the
f7 pawn Bishop to d3 now and here he's
attacking this h-bond and it's not like
in Fischer Spassky that this is a poison
point you can trap it with g6 and
because h5 will break break open the
position kink the d8 was played and you
can also play something like g6 this
does preserve your pawn but then rock to
f6 allowing the roof to infiltrate the
position this this might have even been
better than what Carlson played because
the rook will infiltrate the position
anyway so after Bishop to d3 Carson
played King to d8 starting to activate
the King and now Bishop captures on h7
g6 temporarily trapping the bishop and
now h5 g captures on h5 and rook to f6
so drop hazard you know it still came to
f6 infiltrated the position and there
was a there was some talk of rook to f5
in the commentary like attacking d5
pressuring I mean attacking h5
pressuring d5 not allowing this point to
be pushed because then c5 would be
hanging but nakamora decided to go for
rook to f6 not allowing Carlsen
worship to go anywhere Bishop the c6 was
pretty much the only way to develop the
bishop give it some use but now it
really doesn't have any moves so King to
e7 attacking the rook and now rook to b7
rocked the c7 by Carson night to see to
a5
we have night the e3 c4 Bishop to c2 now
Bishop the c6 b captures on c4 big
captures on c4 and rook to a6 now going
after the a5 pawn a for Bishop captures
a 4 and now Bishop to e4
so Carson now has 2 points for the piece
and there are they're not any connected
points they're just three point islands
so it shouldn't really be a problem you
know Europe Europe a piece three
separate Bonin Islands is shouldn't be a
big deal rook to a5 King to e6 rook
captures on h5 now and c3 so now Carson
has only one extra pawn for the piece
but it's it's a passed pawn and c3
preparing to be pushed on c2 we have
Bishop to b3 check King to d6 Bishop the
c2 now not along with the point to be
pushed Bishop captures and c2 Knight
captures on c2 and now came to e6 and
how do you win this it's it's not very
simple especially when you're playing
the world champion King - f - now hikaru
improves the position of his King f5 so
the King can approach deeper into the
position the rook was blocking it rock
to h3 we have Tim 3:5 rock to D 3 into F
4 by Carlsen rock to d4 check King goes
to g5 now King to f3 rook the c8 rock to
a for rock to c7 rock to a8 and King to
f6
replace X check came back to g5 nights
to d4 and wrote the C for attacking the
knight knife to e6 check King to f6
Knight to f4 a discovered check from the
rook King to e5 and
nights to d3 check teens to d5 and look
to a 2 now not allowing the point to be
pushed and king to d4 now attacking the
knight Knight the c1 was played with a
c2 by Carlsen and this is a very
critical moment in the game here
Nakamura has to play rook to a3 and not
allow Carlson's King to approach deeper
into the position but instead of rook to
a3 Nakamura played rook to a5 and it
seems like it's a perfectly fine move
you know you're winning the f5 pawn and
sooner or later you will sacrifice your
night for this C pawn and then simply
push the Jeep on out of the board as the
answer calls it the the G Pony Express
wrote the c3 check King to f4
when a Kimura rook to c8 now and again
this was probably I'm pretty sure this
was the last chance Nakamura had to play
rook to a3 to again cut the king or out
of approaching this c2 pawn but instead
Nakamura played rope captures an f5 and
here Nakamura was already very low in
time but Carson had like over half an
hour on the clock and he got really
excited because I think Carson also I
think he got the flu or something she
looked pretty sick and Leonard oats the
photographer said that cross and looked
really sick but that he couldn't get a
good photo of him being sick so rook to
e8 course and finds it and this is the
only moves move that gives black a
chance
the idea is rook to e1 attacking the
knight and when the knight moves to b3
then rook to be 1 and then the night
won't really have anywhere to go
you will be threatening promotion so
roof to f7 by Hikaru rook to e1 now as
planned route to d7 check King to d3
King erupted to c7 check King to d2 and
now Knight to b3 check and this is the
position Hikaru probably saw when he
captured that F pawn
he probably calculated King to d1 or
maybe King to eat too
because if you play King to d1 this
simply doesn't work what Hikaru missed
was King to D 3 which is what Carson
played because if you play King to d1
then rook to d7 wins easily but now if
you play King to d3 rook to d7 doesn't
do anything
King to c3 you attack the knight rope to
b7 rook to be one now and you can't
really do anything about this you have
to push the g4 pawn rook captures on b3
and after rook to c7 check King to d2
there's there's no way to win this rook
captures c2 King captures it doesn't
really matter and it's a draw the the
pawn will go up the board so after Kings
to d3 here he carved knew that he blew
it that he will not have a a nice
birthday present tomorrow morning when
he wakes up and he played night to c5
kink the d4 Knight the b3 would check
keep the d3 like to c5 repeating again
here he karo had less than a minute on
the clock King to d4 again Knight to b3
check King to d3 and here it was a
three-fold repetition but Carson didn't
call the arbiter - you know - telling me
it's a draw and here Nakamura I mean it
was a three-fold repetition but Nakamura
still doesn't want to play Knight to c5
he wants that victory for his birthday
birthday tomorrow and he plays g4 so
everybody was very very I'm not gonna
say shocked but very surprised that he
car was still trying to win this so rope
to f1 check King g5 and now rope the b1
as planned and here you don't really
have anything else to do a 95 check
again King III nice to be 3 now Nakamura
is trying to get cost him to grab the
night but if you grab it and rocky
afters and c2 and then the Jeep on will
win the game now
so after night b3 Carson ignores the
night simply King to d3 and I see 5
check King III and after Knight to b3 in
this position cousin called the arbiter
and said that he's about to make
third move that will create a three-fold
repetition so in this position Carson
and Nakamura through the game so as of
this day the the new result between the
two of them is 12 wins Carson 1 win
Nakamura and 24 draws so too bad for
Nakamura could could have been a very
nice birthday tomorrow but you know
you're playing the world champion it's
it's never easy so yeah that's the game
I would like to thank all the richness
Andrew Bergman a Benjamin glides man and
Peter Mitaka for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here I think all for
watching and I will see you soon